well the raiders organizational chart
had more movement than terminal 3 at
mccarran international today
seven players have been activated to the
gameday roster while a few remain on the
covid
reserve list two guys get bumped up from
the practice squad and a practice player
goes to covid quarantine there's a lot
to unpack
a cavalcade of raiders defensive players
were held out of practice this week due
to contact tracing concerns
according to espn nearly all of them are
good to go for tomorrow
defensive lineman cleland furl
linebacker corey littleton and theo
riddick
and of course trent brown are on the
covet list
as for the active roster columns d lyman
chris smith joins
javen white the pride of unlv football
in uniform for tomorrow's game versus
kansas city
white was on the active roster and came
in for one play against the saints in
the home opener but
returned to the practice squad after
veterans regained health white went
undrafted out of unlv but has continued
to impress the coaching staff good for
him